BOOKER.
CAN'T ANSWER THAT TIME.
GIANNIS WITH THE REBOUND, HIS
NINTH.
GOES INSIDE.
LAY-UP IS NO GOOD, BUT A FOUL.
AND MORE FREE THROWS FOR GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
HE'S ALREADY BEEN TO THE LINE
SEVEN TIMES, AND HE'S 6 FOR 7.
>> Jeff: AND HE WAS COING HARD
AND FAST RIGHT AT AYTON.
MARK, YOU MADE THE POINT,
AYTON'S GOT TO SQUARE HIS BODY
UP.
HE'S GOT HIS SHOULDER TRYING TO
ABSORB THE CONTACT.
HE'S GOT TO GET HIS CHEST IN
THERE.
>> Mike: THREE FOULS ON AYTON.
ALREADY FOUR TEAM FOULS FOR
PHOENIX.
WE'RE NOT EVEN FOUR MINUTES IN.
THE FREE THROWS LOOK GOOD
TONIGHT.
HE'S HAD STRETCHES WHERE HE
HASN'T SHOT FREE THROWS SO WELL.
HERE'S WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, MARK.
IT'S INCREDIBLE HOW MANY POUNDS
HE'S PUT ON.
HE'S GROWN A LITTLE BIT.
>> Jeff: WHAT HAS HE GROWN SEVEN
INCHES?
>> Mike: BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
GIANNIS ONCE HAD A GAME WHERE HE
SHOT 17